The joe rogan experience.
An NLP is neuro linguistic linguistic programming.
Is that what you're doing?
And I'll paste it,
but it's mainly to language and think tricks that have popped up from over the
air.
Not all NLP,
you know,
he said,
look,
a little bit of hypnosis,
hypnotic language,
blah blah,
blah.
Right.
And it gets them into learning state.
So what I do is I get a prepared them in a learning state,
give them confidence,
build them up so they can start to take on what Liam teachers.
So they said double whammy.
Really?
So he teach you some brilliance that nice as you are aware.
And then I just do my bit to get them where they have to get to.
Before I met you,
I thought that hypnosis was for idiots.
I thought you'd have to be a dummy.
I'm like,
yeah,
you're getting me with that shit.
And then when you hit the tires me,
I was like,
wait a minute.
This is real.
Wow.
But I tried to explain it to me.
Oh to people,
you know.
I'm like,
it's not what you think.
It's not like you don't know where you are,
you don't know what's going on.
All of a sudden your parents are off.
It's not like that.
It's like you achieve this weird state of mind that you're aware,
do it.
Yes.
All's I do is guide it.
You do it and then the client does it.
Like whenever I do it with you.
Well as we've got an actual friend called Mike Parr,
it was,
I'd been working with him.
He loves it and white and Brown people [inaudible] to help his acting.
Yeah,
he did.
He mentioned me on a program called this morning,
which is a daytime show in England.
And uh,
he went on to it in a soap opera called Emmerdale.
He's normally in a long time and no need less time because I'm not an your
biggest fan by the way.
Yeah.
So yeah.
And we have done work with him and since of going on your show,
which I have to,
I really do appreciate it because my work's gone from a business woman of the
year CEOs and everyone now been,
it's just been,
it's just gone crazy because they needed to convince her and he was at so thanks
very much.
Well,
it's legit.
I'll tell you right now.
I mean,
I don't know about other people,
but you know how to do it.
Thank you again,
it gave me some very interesting understanding about the mind and thought
processes and how it works and that expression that you look like to use all the
time.
Huck allow,
I think about that.
Explain what that is to people.
How can always,
uh,
increasing your peripheral vision?
It's Korea.
It's increasing your awareness just by basically cutting off your chest or
chatter that goes on in your mind.
If you see a Liam,
when he fights before he fights,
he pushes his gloves together and goes into how cloud is every single time.
What that does when,
I haven't shown you that yet,
but I will show you later on if you wish is you anchor the gloves.
She anchor a positive state in the gloves and you push them together and then
you find Hakalau and it just gets you into,
well,
you can explain it.
What's unique about these seminars is,
oh,
I want it to do and here because I've worked with [inaudible] before and all
this stuff that he's teaching.
I'm not,
I know it works myself.
Um,
first time I used Vinny,
the story are,
we all started,
I thought a top level ty called want cow Samara in nickname and [inaudible] you
had like an 8% Kayla ratio and I went to fight him in Jamaica.
I knew I could be in,
but there are a few aspects that you think all right with train and it didn't go
right at a time.
It
threw him off.
I'm not a liar.
Really fucked my shit up.
It fucked you up on Michael Jackson died.
Oh yeah.
Massive Fund.
Everyone knows me.
Knows I'm a massive fan,
but I'm not blaming Michael Jackson.
[inaudible] really?
Where you have a massive,
massive,
yeah.
Do you ever come out to his fights?
You ever smooth criminal course?
Um,
but yes,
I fought this Thai champion in Jamaica.
Like I said,
a few things didn't go right and he smashed me to pieces.
It would,
the first time I ever got stopped,
um,
I knew I could beat him.
No,
I'm good at reading fighters.
I knew I could beat him.
So I begged and begged and begged for the rematch and promote Roy about six,
seven months later,
brought him to England and me and arena,
massive shore biggest showed the country devacy and vineyard spots.
Sportsmen before in the past said,
do you want to have,
if you want to do a little bit of work,
I know it's fun.
I'm mentally strong and mentally strong.
I don't need to do to build up to that fight or for,
you know what?
I'm going to train his idol.
They always,
as I've ever done before,
anywhere,
but there's no point.
You can never be too prepared because they'd all been in.
Can we do a little bit?
And,
um,
we did,
uh,
we did lots of different techniques and we have like keywords like warrior,
one of them.
Worry was the main one.
Yeah.
Bear in mind that the reason why I leave was reluctant to work with me.
It's the first time he met me.
I stole it wheelchair drunk,
steal anyone who was disabled chapters for everyone.
Can Brits,
I was strong.
Charlotte [inaudible],
he's called Richard Smith from members or Alisa.
And um,
anyway,
so it was a reluctant,
because I like to mess about,
you know,
I like to be silly Cetera,
but he came to me and,
and uh,
we,
we work together and my take on this story is I was common saying at the time,
great guy called Rob Cox,
who lives in San Louis,
who knows everything about weight.
I rub Cox holes,
everybody,
everybody's got the kink simple.
And it was compensating with him.
Now Liam came to me and I wanted to put a word in that would,
that,
would that keep him strong?
So it was warrior.
Now.
It was really weird.
As I was compensating,
you can watch it on Youtube when I'm commentating on the fight,
he looks at me at round four cause I can see him and he looks through his p,
his trainer,
Richard Smith and Andy House and his claws news five time world champion as
well.
So it's in a family and he looks over at me and he goes warrior.
He looks straight in my eyes.
I don't ever remember doing that over.
You were like the,
the state I was in my,
no Phi in,
it couldn't hurt me.
And then bearing in mind our bodily smash me a piece in the first fight,
I didn't get hurt with anything.
I would just,
it will occur in some totals day.
I was so on point.
I'll make any mess up.
Our school didn't really,
I'll be pretty convincingly on points.
That's amazing.
And um,
I went to the after party afterwards I'd bottle of water,
sat down,
passed out,
collapsed ambulance,
came and got me,
took me,
it was bill.
I had a really bad concussion.
Wow.
But did you guys like the state I was in in the fight and um,
I didn't feel a thing.
Everything just are,
my eyes didn't feel any people.
We're like,
Hey,
it's actually explained so emotionally invested in it as well.
But when the kids,
you know side,
when he came over he said,
thank you.
I was like,
oh you want me to do that day as well.
So there are a lot that day in his family and I was so overwhelmed by it.
But look,
I mean it's only one aspect of it.
He's got a fantastic culture and Richard Smith and Lisa,
Lisa Smith,
Lisa,
you should we call hot Lisa and all the gangs like bad shit,
you know.
And everyone,
Steve Campbell,
eastern physician,
he's got so many people around him.
I'm just one little bit,
but it was weird because he went,
he went warrior and I said to him,
do you remember saying what are you went no,
I didn't remember.
I'll have to look back at the video and what the concussion probably had a lot
to do with that.
Maybe I'll look back at the video and is a left hook in round form.
I had nearly like Ooh,
spins around and terms the one that probably,
you know it's interesting that that's catching on mental coaching.
It really is and there's a lot of fighters that used to dismiss it that I know
now are using mental coaches.
I've had conversations with them before in the past and I was like,
what do you think about sports psychologists when you think about mentoring or I
don't need that shit.
And then years later,
oh lost her two later,
their minds in a weird place and then they,
they decide,
okay,
I need something like that.
Now.
The thing is I think that fights are won and lost in the changing rooms.
I think that in the locker room as you say,
you know,
one little,
it's like a little tiny bit of anthrax.
It thrown in in a reservoir,
a poison,
a whole say.
And then that's where it was mentally.
I've seen fires in the dressing room who I've trained with in the gym and they
have been so strong at so much power in the gym that had been the best ever.
And I've seen him in the changing rooms and I've seen him start to go up.
The self can be out of place in it strongly money and I can see him just to
flair.
And a lot of fighters do have that problem and I'm dwarfed by the moment.
Yeah.
That's a common thing with everything,
with any kind of performance,
anything where you're doing something that's difficult,
but fighting it has such dire physical consequences that the,
the overwhelming anxiety and the pressure just to you,
you see it so many times guys who were really good fighters,
that they have panic attacks in the dressing room and they just,
they can't handle it until the use as well.
It means you get such a diverse mix of clients that he eats everything is what
it means to you,
isn't it?
So that your fight against you,
whether this fight is tie boxes in the world that they keep matching you with.
And,
um,
and,
and your job,
I'll you,
your interview,
we'll all use like my key that the lines that you have to do while you're
showing.
I think it's all relative to you,
you know,
and anxiety's a big sketch.
Yeah.
Anytime you have to do anything difficult anxiety comes into play,
but it just doesn't come into play in anything remotely clinic except war.
It's like war is like the highest of it.
And then pass you get the low below that is like probably police officers and
first responders and then it's fighters and it's like,
there's nothing like that that walk to the fucking ring,
you know what I mean?
And you're just thinking about did I do enough?
Did I sleep enough that I eat right.
You know,
and you see,
ah,
I see so many.
I think that's why I've kind of got into it as well,
you know,
with different things that I saw so much potential.
She,
I,
you know,
the first time,
well,
the first time I met him I was training someone to fight him.
Oh Wow.
And that was like,
listen,
he's only a kid.
So what you've got to do,
get in his face and punch him in the face.
Art As often as you can.
It'll suit quit.
How wrong was I?
Only 15 who was he?
How old is the other guy?
28 oh Jesus.